[Applause]
i appreciate it thank you very much
what a revved up crowd we have i'm sure
this is
uh because you've been watching the
hearings the january sixth year no just
me okay well uh that's why i'm here to
watch things for you anyway this is kind
of a big thing january 6 remember that
where they tried to coo and the whole
thing
okay so let me just sum it up for you
like if this was a game of clue
it would be captain pumpkin
in the white house with the remote okay
but
a lot of people thought it was going to
be the same old news actually there's a
lot of new footage because there was a
guy a documentary filmmaker who was
embedded
with the proud boys
little note to the proud boys um if
you're going to commit treason don't
bring a film crew
i would say
and
and we know now that i mean everybody
told trump that he lost the election how
did he they have texts from sean hannity
saying to trump no more stolen election
talk
okay that's proof that trump knew that
the calls were coming from inside your
ass
now
this
they pretty much did lay it out pretty
well i got to say that trump was well
fully aware that he lost the election uh
but he still opted to just go with the
lie that it was a big fraud and that he
conspired to thwart
the
i'm so angry about all this
about biden getting elected when he was
fully rightly elected i mean if only
someone
someone had been around to say that
trump was never going to concede the
election
i don't see him leaving under any
condition oh i'm the guy who says he's
not leaving even if he loses the
election people have been saying i'm an
alarmist and i'm crazy because i keep
saying he's not going to leave he's not
going to leave even if he loses the
election
there's a lot more of those but we
didn't want to waste your time
even
ivanka testified by videotape ivanka
while the riot was going on begged him
to do something
uh but of course donald trump one thing
he's learned to tune out it's ivanka
saying daddy please stop
oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and listen to this we found out when
they were the mob was chanting hang mike
pence
trump said maybe our supporters have the
right idea
pence deserves it
yes he wanted to murder his vice
president which is completely normal in
north korea
this is what i would call a smoking
noose
and of course republicans have now meant
to mounted a very very aggressive
defense to all this yes so what
that's what they have only no
refutations only distractions you know
you think what trump was bad what he did
with his number two
what about what amber heard did with her
number two you know that's
their whole
fox news wouldn't even show it
they had their regular programming they
put it on fox business network because i
think we could all agree this is a
business story
the fox news website today had you know
what there was the big thing was on it
uh britney spears
one of her exes crashed her wedding this
is like if during watergate uh the
washington post ran a story about a cher
falling in the pool
you